好，那咱们接着往下说啊。
我觉得咱们在。
学习当编剧之前，有必要先了解一下这个行业。
不熟悉的有很多同学不熟悉，我可以给大家简单讲一下，了解一下目前中国影视行业的现状。
影视这个行业的现状。
简单说。
就是水平低下。
烂片很多。
这个也不是说咱们自己妄自菲薄，这个事情肉眼可见，不管是行内人还是观众，大家都看得到。
确实。
很烂。
咱不用说在世界上，你就在亚洲。
你说日韩。
你说港台。
泰国。
伊朗。
跟位说还有个印度。
都比我们强。
实力都比我们强。
呃，至于为什么这么差呢？
一句话，两句话说不清楚。
有些人说是与审查有关呀，广电总局啊什么的，一句话，两句话说不清楚。我给大家举个例子吧，中国的影视，中国的现在的影视圈有点像一个封闭的高中食堂。
一个封闭的高中市场。
你吃过有好吃的封闭的食堂吗？
不可能的。
一个封闭管理的高中食堂，你不能去别的地方吃，只能在这吃。这家食堂好吃不了，为啥？
因为他包给这个这个食堂承包给这个人的时候，考察的不是他的厨艺。同学们，你明白这个意思吧？
要么是看他能交多少承包费。
要么就看他是不是校长的小舅头。
就这两件考量。
如果是从钱上卡它。
他就失去了拍一个好片子的动力。
如果他是校长小舅子，那他就是没有拍一个好片子的能力。
所以很难出好片子，烂片层层出不穷，就是这个原因封闭。
那我们还要不要做呢？我们学习编剧的意义是什么呢？
我就是希望你。
有朝一日应聘到这个高中食堂做厨师的时候。
用心的炒菜。
我们不要去讲什么大道理，我在这里也不会去给你们讲怎么去改变这种现状。我们作为编剧目前做不到。
我们就脚踏实际把自己的工作做好。有朝一日，我进到这个高中食堂做厨师了。面对我现有的原材料。
和现有的烹饪环境。
用心做好你的菜。
这就是中国影视行业目前的一个大的状态。我不去细讲里面的规则，你们以后都会遇到。但我就跟你说，他现在就是一个封闭的高中食堂，这种情况下导致什么呢？导致了非常多的严重的后果。
比如说导致我们的。
一部分观众。
一部分观众啊开始自暴自弃了，开始老龄化。
老龄化什么意思呢？
你去看啊，我经常观察现在很多很年轻的小年轻一吃饭拿出个pad或者拿个手机。
看武林外传。
或者是看乡村爱情。
还有看爱情公寓的，基本上分这么三股恶势力。
然后看到他在那乐。
我说你这乐什么呢？说，你看刘能赵四马上要打起来了。
我说你知道他们马上要打起来了，你为什么还要看呢？还有什么意思吗？
其实就是烂片太多，逼着他们看在那看老片儿。
这是一个很。
很不正常的收视习惯，因为往往只有老人才这么做。
为什么老人喜欢看戏啊？
比如说他们去听京剧。
包公的铡美案。
对吧包工砸陈世美。
你说今天这个戏包公会不会铡掉陈世伟，对吧？会不会当中出岔头了，在铡的过程中到底铡了几刀铡死没有？有没有铡到一半。有人说刀下留人，然后来了一个这个陈世伟的干爹，是个太监。
对吧那是包龙兴。
没有这种悬念的，看的都是已知。
就是老龄化的观众喜欢看已知，年轻观众应该喜欢看未知呀，未知的故事才最有吸引力嘛，对不对？这点道理都不明白吗？所以现在就把观众逼得硬生生老龄化了。那还有一部分观众。
他没有老龄化，那你国产剧不好看吗？
我看美剧。
我看韩剧，我看外国的剧，对吧？
他们就是有点西方话。
这种情况也非常明显。我跟你说，你看这几年啊有个很明显的趋势。
你从女孩子整容你就能看出来。
他们咋整？欧式的大双眼皮儿。
开个眼角。
然后又窄又翘的小尖儿鼻子。
然后下巴也往前推一推。
再削一削脸。
你说这个这种长相。
你再染个头发，带个美瞳。
就是白人嘛。
这种审美哪来的？为什么会大家现在年轻人普遍觉得这种长相好看呢，不好看，人家不这么整嘛？为什么会觉得这种长相好看呢？其实就是审美希望化。
我们的文化。
照人家比差点意思，等于被人带走了。
就是文化软实力差点意思，影视占很大的一部分。
所以我们作为编剧啊，我们如果要从事编剧啊，一定要肩负起这个责任。
我们树立一点我们的文化自信，慢慢的。
再引导回来。
这些不能怪观众，你没有好片子给人家看，人家当然看那些了。
对吧。
这是一点。
还有些这个社会上的这个声音啊。
老骂这个咱们影视行业出了现在出了很多。
小鲜肉。
流量明星。
对吧出了很多小鲜肉，说这些人把影视行业搞坏了，对吧？他们挣这么多钱，科学家没有人关注，就就经常搞这种。
他没有根据的类比，你说是不是小鲜肉把影视搞坏了？
我可能呢？
小鲜肉鲜肉，它只是一种原材料啊。
对吧它怎么可能影响整个影市呢？它只是审美的一种。除非你说天天吃面条，天天吃面条，说了不吃面条，还吃面条那种。
小鲜肉可能是呃这让你有点崩溃，但是你如果全部换成老腊肉，你吃了不崩溃吗？天天吃老腊肉，对吧？它只是呃审美的一种。
它不会影响大局，真正它就像你这个高中食堂里的一一种原料，它怎么会影响你整个菜品的质量呢？
还是从厨师身上找问题。
好吗？就不要去怪这个小鲜肉。然后啊咱们这个中国的影视行业还有一个很明显的趋势，就是电影啊。
和电视剧。
目前差距越来越大。
我们看到电影这几年啊，中国的电影水平慢慢的呃在往上走，有一点点跟嗯国际接轨的。
趋势了，但是电视剧越来越差，比前几年还差，经典片子已经很少出现了。
注水很严重。
其实电影呃这也造成了现在影视圈有一个歧视链。你拍电影的就瞧不起拍电视剧的。我给大家讲个故事啊，我前几年嗯在一次开会的时候遇到一个很年轻的女编剧，可能也就是大学刚毕业吧。嗯，别人介绍了一下，说你们俩是同行互相认识一下。我呢因为是呃做电视剧为主。
然后我们俩就握了个手，我说哎，咱们是同行，你好，结果他很郑重的纠正了我一下，说你好，我是做电影的。
意思呢就是他比较高级。其实啊电影跟电视剧原本。
本质上来说没有那么大的差距。
他只是。
驱动形式不一样，在这里我可以给大家讲一下啊。
就说电影啊电影。
是结构。
和画面。
的艺术。
然后呢，电视剧。
是人物。
和细节。
的艺术。
啥意思呢？我我更通俗点说，电视剧往往是人物驱动的。
电影呢往往是事件驱动。
不信我问大家一个问题，我就说电视剧。
你们看过爱情公寓吗？
看过对吧？
我问你爱情公寓讲什么的，你回答我。
你大概率的会说爱情公寓就是讲嗯曾小贤、胡亦菲、关谷神奇他们在一块儿乱七八糟的事儿。
我说那什么事儿呢？
你一下子想不起来。
人物驱动，你只记得那些人物了。
对吧。
电影。
我问你。
哎，前几年有个电影2012你看过吗？
你说哎看过我说那个电影讲什么的？
你说哎那是个灾难片，讲的世界末日呀、地球毁灭呀、大洪水呀，挺惨的。
我说那那个电视那个电影的主角是谁呀？
谁最后拯救了地球啊？
很想哎。
好像是个博士。
还是个警察。
还是个特工的。
谁知道去？
你记不得了，但是你记得这个事儿。
就说明电影还是事件驱动的，电视剧是人物驱动。
那为什么会有这种？
为什么会有这种区别呢？其实本质上啊它是由于呃播出形式的不同，而反向导致它有这些不同的。
而且电影一般预算比较大，所以做的会比电视剧精致一点。但这些年的这个差距已经越来越小了。
我跟你讲，是其实本质上是播出形式的区别。
导致他更偏重结构和画面，他更偏注人物和细节。为什么呢？
播出的区别是什么？电影在哪播？
电影在电影院里播，你要买票。
对吧。
他是个消费行为。
你买了票了呀，我花了钱了呀，消费行为。然后在在一个电影院里。
小黑屋里看他俩小时。
对吧电视剧呢你是在家里躺着或坐沙发上捧这个pad，捧这个手机看。
那你可不是看里面的人物吗？你要他。
绵长温柔陪伴啊，它等于电视剧。
讲究的是陪伴。
对吧他讲究的是陪伴，然后呢，他又是人物驱动。
那你说来一个人物陪伴你。
这是啥？
这是爱情呀，对不对？所以看电视剧其实是谈恋爱的一种体验，明白吗？
明白吗？
那电影呢？
电影你花钱。
买两个装。
的享受。
这是什么？
如果电视剧是恋爱。
电影就是。
就是嫖娼。
就是这种区别。
所以。
那体验肯定不一样。
电影更讲究服务。
他需要让你指挥票价。
而电视剧呢。
他更让你牵挂。
让你欢喜，让你愁，让你忧。
但是这几年啊我们说至少从好莱坞来说，电视剧的制作规格。
和他讲故事的方式已经接近电影了。
或者是跟电影一样。你看有有几部美剧像罪夜之奔开始的，它就是完整的电影结构。
然后后来什么权力的游戏呀、西部世界呀，这些完全就是电影规格呀。
你看这种电视剧，那。
有点像你本来打算谈个恋爱，对吧？这个隔壁王阿姨给你介绍了个对象，处挺好，然后到了那一天。
一呀哎呀。
姑娘。
你会的挺多。
不收钱吧。
姑娘什哥，这是爱情啊，对吧？多惊喜，为什么？因为他他以前也是搞电影的呀，对吧？退役下来的。
所以说电影的电视剧啊。
，咱们不必呃搞得那么呃从咱们编剧的角度，咱们不用不用不要去搞那么多区别，不要搞那么多歧视。
你一个故事出来之后，他适合做电影就做电影，适合做编视呃电视剧，就做电视剧。因为说到底咱们编剧来说，咱们编剧啊，我给编剧有个定义啊。
要讲故事的人。
讲故事的人，因为不管是电影还是电视剧，他不都是讲故事嘛。
然后他讲故事讲的是什么的故事？
他们的文学依据都是编剧的剧本。
等于你才是最初最早最和这个故事，最原始的形态是你讲的，你其实就是个讲故事的人。
对吧讲故事，我们说讲故事的人。
这个事情这个。
这个定义没有那么简单的。
这个事儿可不小，为啥呢？我这里给大家讲点题外话故事。
故事啊。
前几年我看了一本书，那本书很流行的呃人类简史，你们可能也听过由瓦尔克拉利写的。
他里也有一个观点。
说故事是人类历史的起点。
它是个起点。
什么意思呢？就是人从讲从讲故事开始。
还成人的。
他把这次称为人类的第一次认知革命。
咱们小时候课本上咋说的，说人跟动物的区别是使用工具。
但后来这种观点啊慢慢的好像呃被大家抛弃了。为啥？因为动物其实也会啊。
我去年看那个地球脉动，那星星拿着一根棍儿，蘸上点那个那个诱饵插到蚂蚁窝里掉蚂蚁吃。
工具啊它会动物也会，那猴子还会拿石头砸椰子呢。
所以由阿尔塞拉利提出这个观点，大家普遍认可说人跟动物的区别其实是可以讲故事。
故事。
而且他有个很直接的证据，就是说。
我们以前普遍认为。
呃，人类是由这个人类变过来的，这个大家都认可。但是原本的观点认为人是由不同的人类变来的。像咱们中国这一块的，就是由这个山顶洞物人啊、北京人变来的，这是以前的观点。欧洲人就是尼安德特人变的。
但是后来人类学家发现一个问题。
说其实地球上通通过DNA发现，地球上所有的现存的人都是八九万年前从那个智人来的，非洲的一针叫智人，他们走出非洲。
横扫全球，干掉了其他所有的人。
那他是为什么这么牛逼，这么厉害，能把其他人都干掉呢？
人类简史上说就是因为。
他经历了第一次认知革命，或者说他会讲故事。
他会讲故事，把其他人干掉。那你说呃呃治人就到处溜达，看到别的人就叨叨叨叨叨叨给人讲故事，就给人叨叨死了嘛。
显然不是这样的那我们就说讲故事的定义。
在这里讲故事就是虚构啊。
就说他们开始拥有了虚构能力。
导致了他们。
一下子变猛了。
可以干掉其他人类。
其实啊从考古发现，当时智人在这个进化这这个战这个这条路上并不占优势。欧洲的尼安德特人是最厉害的，为啥？
首先他个儿大。
个大他又有劲儿啊，他高啊，对吧？其次呢。
他脑容量还大。
人又聪明，等于是又高又聪明。
你怎么跟人打？
而且。
呃，还有证据显示，尼安德特人当时已经有衣服了，人家会做衣服了。
穿着皮袄。
你治人还光着腚呢，你都好意思统治地球，人家有衣服。
所以说当时从计划的角度来讲，年安德特人是最最最最占优势的，但是他唯独就差了这个，他不会讲故事，就被致灭了，就是说他不会虚构。
不够直观的话，我再给你说啊，假设来智人从非洲走出来了。
对吧。
走到欧洲。
走到一个狭这个山河坡河边跟尼安德特人狭路相逢，就要干一下子。这一条河就够一只呃，在这儿呃抓鱼吃饭呃，洗澡喝水的。
那就要干一下子。
为什么智然能赢呢？
首先，致人人多。
尼安德特人一针最多就能滑落三五十个。
怎么花啦的？
兄弟姐妹、媳妇、孩子爹妈。
一个大家族呗，就这点人了。
你通过血原凝凝聚。
团队。
智人则不一样。
智人通过虚构来凝聚团队。
比如说他们聊咱们几个，咱们这一堆。
都是一个村的。
对吧或者说咱们这一堆这一堆都是狮子的儿女。
就是他们有一个，比如说他们有一个共同的一个logo。
那他们就是一伙的。
或者说咱们这一堆儿对吧？祖上都是喝某一条河的水长大的。
我们就是黄河儿女。
他就有故事，他就能圈更多的人。这更多的人支持人人想想哎，也是哈，那咱们就应该一伙。
他就用到这个虚构能力。
他就圈的人更多。
第二，还有一点。
他们可以布置战术。
就是你虚构这个。
不光是可以虚构故事，还可以虚构。
假设比如说来。
明天要干仗了，智人这就开会啊。
说来明天你们几个。
左右包抄。
你们几个从后面掏，我带着你们从正面冲，对吧？你们几个娘们搁家做饭。
一上一上午可能打不完，我们得带点呃中饭。
安排的明白。
你再看那个尼安德特人那边。
三十几个人。
也也在那围一堆，点着火烤肉吃。
假设你穿越过去，你想救他们，你跟他们说哎。
别吃了，这吧是啥时候了，还有心思吃，咱们研究研究战术吧。
明天等。
智人来了以后，骂你这句话一说。
尼安德他人马上炸包了，治人治人哥打仗对吧？来干吧，为什么他们不懂你在说假设。
他们就跟动物一样。
就听到什么就反应什么。
他没有这个假设的能力。
所以你看他从人数上，从战术上都吃亏，你穿着貂。
也没有用，穿个皮袄也没有用。
你别看知人光的定，他通过一个认知能力，在所有的其他都在劣势的情况下，通过讲故事统治全球，这就是讲故事的魅力。好吧，这是个题外话。我就说我们编剧是讲故事的人。
我们开创了人类的历史。
我们还在书写人类的现在，我们必将。
走向人类的未来。好吧，这就是我们编剧工作的魅力。